tous les ans 59 millions de vies
humaines disparaissent de la surface de
la terre mais savez vous quelle est la
principale cause de ces décès les
guerres les pollutions peut-être ou bien
alors le tabagisme avec la dangereuse
cigarette ou bien alors la sédentarité
en restant voterait toute la journée sur
son fauteuil
en réalité la première cause de la
première cause de décès qui emporte avec
elle plus de 11 millions de vies
humaines
tous les ans se trouve en réalité juste
sous notre nez on la retrouve partout
elle est tout à fait légal on a surtout
pris l'habitude de la stocker chez nous
dans nos placards et dans nos
réfrigérateurs va terminer bien souvent
sa course dans notre assiette puis dans
notre bouche parfois dans la poubelle
bon c'est notre nourriture bien sûr
alors moi ça fait ça fait quatre ans en
fait que je me que j'écris des articles
et que je mets des enquêtes sur la santé
sur la nutrition et ça fait en réalité
plus de sept ans plus de sept ans que je
me passionne pour l'alimentation pour
ses secrets pour ces mensonges et aussi
pour ses promesses et à l'origine de
cette passion vers des soucis de santé
mais rien de bien grave
j'avais à l'époque une capacité
respiratoire qui était quasi inexistante
d'ailleurs je pouvais pas respirer
j'avais rien du tout c'était c'était le
néant et ça a été détectée totalement
par hasard alors que j'accompagnais ma
mère chez sans allergologue et pourra le
confirmer elle est là mais j'ai fait
tous les tests du médecin et et il m'a
dit ils n'en revenaient pas il ne
croyait pas parce qu'en fait les
résultats étaient si faibles qu'il
pensait que sa machine ne fonctionnait
pas pourtant ça c'était bien mené qui ne
marchaient pas qui ne fonctionnait pas
alors dans cette histoire le plus
dérangeant pour moi c'était pas ça
c'était véritablement série no farah
gîte à répétition ces horreurs là qui me
prenaient à la gorge et qui me prenait
le nez et que j'ai choisi au final 2-2
traité comme tout le monde j'ai donc
allé voir mon médecin m'a prescrit toute
une batterie d'antibiotiques et puis ça
allait fonctionner
et puis après tout recommencer c'est
bien le pire parfois alors devant cette
spirale infernale véritablement bas il
ya des amis qui m'ont dit mais j'ai un
ami mais regarde ce que tu es dans ton
assiette
hélas là ce fut le déclic je me suis dit
mais oui mais c'est bien sûr notre
alimentation n'est-elle pas notre
premier médicament
après tout et c'est à partir de ce
moment-là que j'ai regardé un petit peu
plus
attentivement à ce que je mettais dans
mon assiette j'ai commencé à me
renseigner à lire des ouvrages sur les
bienfaits les dangers de ce qu'on mange
j'aime bien le dire comme ça mais en
fait j'ai été mon propre cobaye j'ai
retiré les choses que je mangeais en
abondance et que j'ai retiré pas que
j'ai remplacé par d'autres et ce qu'il
faut retenir de cette histoire c'est que
j'ai réussi à résoudre tous mes soucis
de santé sans la moindre rechute
simplement en faisant attention à ce que
je mange et alors alors nous y voilà
nous sommes au coeur du sujet au coeur
du problème c'est notre alimentation
et dieu seul sait que c'est compliqué
compliqué parce qu'en fait tout le monde
pense détenir la vérité
tenez par exemple certains pensent qu'il
faut manger tout cru pour être en bonne
santé ce sont les crudivores pour eux la
cuisson c'est un blasphème un générateur
de composés toxiques qui va altérer la
qualité des aliments
ces personnes pourraient la cuisson
c'est le mal vous en avez d'autres ben
c'est qu'il pense que ce sont nos
ancêtres chasseurs cueilleurs du
paléolithique qui se nourrissent et
muent les paléo comme on les appelle
refuseront à gérer la moindre céréales
la moindre goutte de lait ou le moindre
morceau de fromage
ils s'interdisent aussi tous les
produits industriels rien que ça à
l'extrême
vous avez d'autres qui vont refuser tous
les aliments qu'on a l'habitude de
manger le lait le beurre la viande lait
yaourt la mayonnaise aussi sont les
végétaliens même le miel et ben ali leur
alimentation
en fait il ne tolère que les végétaux
alors on pourra faire toutes les blagues
qu'on veut sur eux mais inviter à un
végétalien à dîner qui vient avec un
bouquet c'est un cadeau ou un dessert
bon bref vous savez vous avez compris où
je veux en venir c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué parce qu'en fait on est tous
perdus dans cette jungle alimentaire il
ya des avis des recommandations partout
on sait plus quoi penser donc on a le
droit en fait de se retourner vers des
grandes recommandations qui existent
elles sont là et on les a souvent
entendu sous forme de chansons à la télé
et la musique vous la connaissez tous
manger cinq fruits et légumes par jour
pour les fibres et vitamines sans
oublier les produits laitiers pour le
calcium pour bien grandir et à voir les
os solides n'ont pas de fracture vient
alors le morceau de viande midi et soir
pour éviter les carences en b12 certains
certains savent
et ces recommandations elles ont été
reprises sous forme de grandes pyramides
et ses grandes pyramides vont nous
donner grandes tendances alimentaires
les aliments que nous devons manger la
quantité que nous devons manger pour
être en bonne santé mais alors est-ce
que ces pyramides
voilà vous avez vu ces pyramides
véritablement sacré elle pourrait être
en fait la solution au problème on
pourrait les croire
si seulement elles n'étaient pas
perverti par les intérêts privés les
intérêts financiers et là ça commençait
à être moins drôle je me pose la
question peut-on faire confiance à ces
recommandations
quand le grand patron qui les valide
fricote de très près de trop près même
avec les fabricants de les deux
saucissons et fromages moi je réponds
non je pense pas alors pour nous
rassurer pour me rassurer et pour
essayer de crédibiliser un peu ses
recommandations bas les états ils vont
s'armer d'experts les experts qui vont
être là pour tout contrôler tout
vérifier ils vont partager vraiment une
parole sacrée qui est impossible à
remettre en cause sinon on va vous
accusés d'alimenter la théorie du
complot exactement comme ils le font
pour moi
et pourtant et pourtant mes enquêtes sur
ces personnalités parce que c'est ce que
j'aime bien faire et c'est ce qui ne
plaît pas révèle une proximité qui
dérangeante qui est même scandaleuse
avec l'industrie agroalimentaire et
pharmaceutique
une proximité qui est alimenté par
l'argent toujours l'argent et les
cadeaux aussi et pour vous saisissiez
toute la portée de cette emprise huit
experts sur dix qui sièges dans ces
instances ont un avis qui est biaisé
transformer moulé par les doléances de
l'industrie agroalimentaire pour vous
dire l'organisation mondiale de la santé
elles mêmes dénoncent des paradoxes
alimentaires des recommandations
incohérentes dans de nombreux pays dits
développés à vous demander un exemple et
bien les pays les plus gros
consommateurs de produits laitiers donc
apports de calcium au solide et bien ce
sont ces pays là qui ont la plus
mauvaise santé osseuse qui ont le plus
de fractures
bizarre
on dira juste que c'est bizarre et même
les diabétiques vont souffrir de ces de
ses intérêts privés avec les industriels
vous avez ici le guide de référence
alimentaire qui a été établi pour aider
les diabétiques à lutter contre cette
maladie
eh bien il n'échappe pas aux tentacules
de l'industrie agro alimentaire
il a été financé payé par la célèbre
société en bouteille de soda sucré qui
est un petit peu suspecté de jouer un
rôle dans l'épidémie de diabète et
d'obésité aujourd'hui à l'école peut se
poser la question aussi mais nos enfants
ne sont pas épargnés
en fait ne rêvez pas c'est même pire nos
décideurs politiques officiellement
demandé à la bien aimée et ô combien
altruiste on le sait tous industries du
sucre d'éduquer les enfants aux
principes d'une alimentation saine et
comme nos têtes pensantes non décidément
rien faut le dire ils ont également
invité les parents et les enseignants à
boire les bonnes paroles de l'industrie
alors je pourrai des balles et des
exemples comme ça pendant des heures
j'en ai plein mais je pense que vous
avez saisi l'idée que je pourrais
résumer comme ça assez on a donné ou
louent les clés de la bergerie
véritablement et j'aimerais faire ce
constat avec vous avec vous ce soir
c'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous sommes devenus des
ogres nous sommes devenus des oeuvres
notre excès de consommation notre ex et
de produits industriels et transformé
nous rend véritablement malade et nous
tue aujourd'hui nous sommes aussi
devenus des feignants nos talents de
cuisiniers vont se résumer à réchauffer
un plat au four micro-ondes bien choisir
son morceau de salade dans une
sandwicherie ça ce sont d'incroyables
tard aujourd'hui nous sommes aussi
devenus des zombies
ouais notre diversité alimentaire se
résume à la blancheur du pain du sucre
et de la farine suffit de nous voir dans
les centres commerciaux
mais comme salah gâteaux biscuits
gâteaux offerts n'arrête pas c'est à
croire que la couleur des poivrons et
des brocolis nous terrifie que et
finalement c'est peut-être le pire mais
aujourd'hui rendez vous compte
manger sainement faisant un minimum
attention c'est devenu une maladie
mentale
ça s'appelle l'orthorexie j'ai fait le
test j'en suis atteint nos dérives
alimentaire aura un impact direct et du
rap sur notre environnement qu'ils
soient proches et éloignés il faut le
savoir
et parmi les pires ce sont les élevages
industriels ceux là mêmes qui nous
permette à tous d'acheter des côtelettes
de vaud des poulets congelés à bas prix
eh bien ils sont responsables de
désastres environnementaux
de destruction c'est ces élevages
industriels sont responsables de
déforestation massive dans le monde
entier les sanctuaires de body verte de
biodiversité sont détruits les trésors
perdus qui sont irrécupérables et pour
nourrir et installer ce bétail 70% des
terres agricoles de la planète sont
monopolisés 70% ne laisse au final
qu'une infime partie pour la production
de fruits et de légumes pour les hommes
et le pire peut-être avec ses élevages
c'est que c'est l'une des activités les
plus polluantes de la planète et vous
savez que l'évolution du climat c'est
quand même quelque chose de préoccupant
aujourd'hui il ya des perspectives
plutôt pessimiste et je suis gentil
et bien selon les estimations les moins
dramatiques sur ce sujet est belle et
les élevages industriels sont
responsables d'au moins 15% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre 15%
c'est plus que tous les transports de la
planète réunis alors pour assouvir cette
faim insatiable en protéines animales
que l'on a
nous sommes devenus des experts en
massacres de masse 100 milliards 100
milliards d'animaux terrestres et marins
sont tués tous les ans pour satisfaire
ce besoin
un véritable holocauste des temps
modernes qui se déroule chaque jour dans
le monde entier et l'immense majorité de
ces animaux d'élevage sont maintenus
puis tué dans des conditions de vie
effroyable
comment on dit ah oui loin des yeux loin
du coeur alors le bien-être animal dans
cette dans cette logique oublier tout
simplement l'idée par exemple pour
obtenir un oeuf lambda tout ce qu'il ya
de plus classique une poule pondeuse
aura le bec coupé à vivre dès la
naissance pour éviter de picorer d'un
lâcher les preuves de ses copines
ensuite elle va placer sera mis dans des
hangars dans des cages étroites ou alors
à l'équivalent d'une feuille a4 pour
vivre et tout cela sans jamais voir la
lumière du jour et les poussins mâles
détruit noyer broyé ou jetés ils ne
savent tout simplement pas et c'est
malheureusement le même constat que l'on
peut faire pour la production intensive
de lait de viande et de foie gras que
l'on prie ce temps en fin d'année
c'est tout notre système qui s'emballe
en entier avec des scandales à
répétition et des contrôles sanitaires
avec de tic il faut le savoir mais
pourtant on au lieu de se résigner et un
peu de culpabiliser après tout ce que je
vais vous dire on a en fait tous les
moyens d'agir on a tous les moyens de
changer les choses par nos choix
alimentaires qu'on fait au quotidien
consommer c'est voter c'est peut-être
facile à dire mais c'est une réalité
on vote dès qu'on achète quelque chose
on façonne le monde avec nos achats on
n'influence les stratégies de
l'agroalimentaire ont fait évoluer
l'offre et rendez vous compte qu'il
suffirait qu'on arrête d'acheter quelque
chose et pour que cette chose là ne se
vendent plus en fait bon alors c'est pas
mon objectif ce sens vous faire changer
vos habitudes alimentaires de j'ai pas
envie d'y voir ou à manger comme un
homme préhistorique
ce serait prétentieux non j'ai envie de
partager avec vous cinq conseils cinq
conseils un mélange de mon sens mais
aussi de recherche scientifique sérieuse
que vous pourrez tous essayé d'appliquer
et de partage et à la fin c'est le
conférencier vous en avez envie
alors pour le premier essayons de
remplir la moitié de notre assiette par
des végétaux
parce que ces végétaux vous apportez une
multitude d'éléments excellent pour
notre santé aussi pour notre moral on
doit négliger aucun légume
aucun fruit aucune couleur alors qu'ils
soient bio surgelés et en conserve à la
vapeur ou en gratin
ils doivent aussi passer c'est simple
pour vous rassurer l'école de santé
publique de harvard aux états unis
probablement la plus sérieuse et l'arrêt
plus réputés sur ce sujet elle
recommande cette assiette là mon
deuxième conseil ce serait évitons au
maximum les ingrédients imprononçable
bien alors les ingrédients qu'on ne
comprend pas ou tout simplement les
aliments qui en contiennent trop je vous
demande ce que vous serez tentés de
manger une blanquette de veau précuites
au but à matt monosodique par exemple ou
alors mieux glace à la vanille et
pessiot glycéro phosphate de calcium
perso moi non je sais pas vous mais je
préfère savoir ce qui va dans mon
assiette et ce qui va aller dans mon
corps au moins en essayant de suivre ce
conseil on va faire le tri entre ce qui
est bon et ce qui est moins bon c'est un
premier filtre mon troisième conseil et
les fondamentale essayons d'aller faire
un maximum de courses au marché pourquoi
pas en allant au marché vous allez
directement donner votre argent aux
producteurs locaux faisaient donc le
soutenir vous allez également bénéficié
de prêts avantageux et faire des
économies
parce que vous allez court circuiter
toute la chaîne de l'agroalimentaire
mais vous allez aussi également
bénéficié de deux nouvelles variétés de
fruits et légumes donc ça va développer
votre curiosité vous
donc vous allez naturellement
diversifier votre alimentation et c'est
aussi important
mais si vous allez faire plus de fois
vous courses au marché vous allez moins
fréquenté les grandes surfaces ces
grandes surfaces la qui propose les
tentations souvent inutiles souvent
onéreuses aussi mais surtout et parfois
néfastes pour notre santé bon 4ème
conseil ce serait un bon sens également
et si on nous remettent à la cuisine
nous installer à table pour manger avec
des amis ou de la famille j'aimerais
vraiment que l'on reprenne plaisir a
épluchés et découpés des plats et des
recettes qui nous font plaisir et
j'aimerais qu'on arrête tout de suite de
penser que réchauffer un plat au four
micro-ondes c'est de la cuisine ça n'en
est pas on est d'accord
alors au lieu de s'installer devant la
télé et de dévorer son plein en cinq
minutes
non moi je dis on se cache ok on prépare
à manger on fait un bon plat avec des
bons amis de la famille s'installe à
table et on partage ce moment ce serait
ça un petit peu l'idée finalement et ce
sera le dernier pensée pour ce soir
essayons de devenir végétalien jour sur
deux essayons de bannir les produits
animaux un jour sur deux alors si on
suit les recommandations officielles les
plus sérieuses à et indépendante sur ce
sujet on peut sans le moindre souci pour
notre santé jeunes insiste là-dessus se
passer des produits animaux trois à
quatre jours par semaine sans problème
tout simplement un jour sur deux en fait
ce que ce que je vous propose c'est du
bon sens quelque part on mange moins on
mange moins de produits animaux mais on
mange bien on choisit de la qualité et
vous savez je vais terminer sur ces mots
mais l'espèce humaine elle a survécu
pendant des millions d'années sans
produits laitiers sans les son fromage
sans yahoo
mais aussi sans bon sens audard et sans
barbe à papa et on s'en porte pas plus
mal vraiment alors aujourd'hui notre nos
dérives alimentaires n'ont jamais été
autant responsable de désastres
environnementaux elle n'aura jamais été
autant responsables d'actes de cruauté
envers les animaux
elle n'aura jamais été autant
responsable de la dégradation de notre
état de santé maladies cardiovasculaires
hypertension diabète et j'en passe alors
si vous essayez de suivre un deux trois
ou tous ces conseils à la fin de faire
de cette conférence
je peux vous garantir que vous allez
incontestablement améliorer votre état
de santé
vous allez limiter les actes de cruauté
envers les animaux vous allez également
préserver notre précieuse planète et ça
c'est des idées qui méritent d'être
partagées merci